hallöchen meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zur vorstellung vom
bildblog also dem amboss
ich hab euch ja gefragt ob ich eine
vorstellung machen soll wo ich das ganze
ein bisschen besser beschreiben und ihr
meint jetzt ziemlich alle ja mach das
mal und habe ich mir gedacht ja okay
dann macht das mal
also ich hab mir schon ein bisschen was
aufgebaut ein paar tests ja das sieht
alles sehr kompliziert aus aber ich hab
da schon ein wenig was aufgebaut ich
werde euch vielleicht zeigen wozu das
gut ist und zwar fangen wir direkt mal
an mit dem crafting also erstmal der
amboss der wird in der 12 41h
implementiert also hinzugefügt und das
ist ein werkzeug womit ihr reparieren
können so sieht er aus den findet ihr im
inventar hier an der stelle also unter
degression blogs findet ihr den normalen
n will einen leicht beschädigten endl
und einen sehr beschädigten will also
einen sehr beschädigten amboss warum
sehr beschädigt je öfter die den ihr den
benutzten runterfällt oder so desto
beschädigter wird der so der amboss kann
nämlich auch zur zum bau von falun
eingesetzt werden und zwar habe ich das
hier aufgebaut hier ist eine schaltung
diät hier zum schalter wenn ich dir
drücke zieht er den blog weg und der
amboss fällt herunter
das heißt ihr könnt auch fallen machen
wenn ihr auftritt fällt numbers auf den
roten erleidet der schaden so er ich
komme ganz kurz und zwei ich mir notizen
gemacht
ich zeige euch erst mal ganz kurz wie
man den kräften und zwar gehen wir dann
einfach ein crafting table oben drei
blöcke von ihren damals war das anders
aber jetzt mit der neuen 12 b 42 jahren
der ich mich gerade befinde ich verlinke
euch das video mal unten von der 12 42 a
also in den video antworten da seht ihr
dann auch wie das alles kräfte wird und
so weiter
dann bekommt er einen n will den stelle
ich jetzt einfach mal hierhin den schnee
nicht beachten die brauchte nicht ich
packe ich weg so nun haben wir hier den
entweder machen einfach rechtsklick
drauf dann können wir den benutzten hier
sehen wir schon reparieren und name und
jetzt ein komisches werkzeug also diesen
blog halt wie bei einer spiele wo man
also mit da drauf haut da nehme ich
jetzt zum beispiel wenn ein diamant wort
wie ihr seht ich habe schon 300 1 level
das ist ein wenig benutzt und dann kann
ich das hier einfach umbenennen zum
beispiel auf
konz langes ding ja das kostet mich nun
so packte habe ich und das heißt in konz
langes ding natürlich ich bin gar dem
creative mord das heißt wir wollen keine
idee abgezogen das ist es relativ egal
aber ich zeige es euch mal ganz kurz
weiter und zwar habe ich einen wurden
spot obwohl dafür kann ich eigentlich
auch eben erst relativ motor ausgehen
damit ihr das seht 301 ich hab ich ein
gutes wort das ist halb kaputt das ist
drei viertel kaputt
die beiden packe ich da rein und dann
seht ihr schon enchantment kostet kostet
bisher 1 also welcher zunächst angegeben
habe das nenne ich nur apache dance
einfach keine ahnung
das heißt ich machen aus zwei kaputten
sachen eins hab dafür acht verbraucht
und ihr seht meine xp hier unten sind
bei 293 also sind acht untergegangen und
ich habe wieder ein neues schwert des
tab hat stellen und hier habe ich jetzt
was langes ding also so genau
funktioniert der der geht dann immer
wieder ein bisschen kaputter aber das
dauert halt eigentlich und ja es gab
auch damals die bucks dass wenn ein
amboss irgendwo runter fällt hier dann
wird er zu einem ungeschickten amboss
also wenn der feuer beschädigt waren
dann runter fällt wird er wieder
unbeschädigt allerdings wird der letzte
in dem letzten snapshot also 12 41 b
wird das behoben und es gibt auch den
fehler dass der amboss noch keine
richtige fall textur hat also travel und
so weiter die haben alle fall texturen
aber das ist eigentlich gar nicht so
schlimm
wissenswertes ist dass man durch dieses
ding auch getötet werden kann also
spieler und auch npcs und auch im
multiplayer der dazu komme ich aber zum
ende und zwei mich da und da schon etwas
aufgebaut das ist ein clans war es das
auch der fünfte block in minecraft neben
sand kies gezündeten tt und dem drachen
das quasi der schwerkraft ausgesetzt ist
also welches auch runter fallen kann
wenn man darunter das abo mit dem amboss
kann man auch nachträglich buchtitel
ändern das habe ich jetzt nicht gezeigt
dass kann ich mal nah kommen das kann ja
eigentlich selber denken oder dass wir
nicht ein buch in dem man dann nach ein
paar kampf wohl das kleinere ihm zeigen
mein gott wenn jetzt schon extrem wieder
mache dann kann ich zu ihm machen wo
habe ich dann überhaupt bücher hörbücher
dokter also schreiben wir mal ein buch
schreiben ein verdammt ich alles kaputt
schreibe ich ein buch so
sein entschluss so zackig rhein gleich
in den namen ändern zu airbus nehme ich
hier das buch kostet 5
sehr schön ein typischer buchreport.de
vergraben oder vergraben jetzt woher
vergabe ich jetzt sehr gut
also ändert ihr habt ihr grad gesehen
wie toll man das alles kaputt machen
kann
den setzt er ganz kurz wieder drauf und
zwar komplett dazu er später noch mal
also man kann damit auch buchtitel
ändern und man erleidet schaden wenn man
von einem gefallenen an bord getroffen
wird und das zeige ich euch jetzt wenn
man davon nämlich getötet wird später
schoss crash bei vorliegen endet also
ich hab das hier schon ein bisschen
aufgebaut mit ein bisschen redstone
durchsetzung schalter ich mache mich mal
kurz aus dem game und raus game 0
seht alles voll so putz zweieinhalb
herzen abzug bekommen
und zwar herunter gefallen dann genau
auf mich drauf und zwar fällt ein amboss
zwei blöcke tief auf einen spieler mit
voller gesundheit erleidet diese ein
herz schaden bei drei blöcken 2
bei vier blöcken drei herzen bei fünf
glocken 4 hört bei fünf blöcken vier
herzen und so weiter dann bei zehn
blöcken neuen herz und bei 11 blöcken
erleidet der spieler alle zehn herzen
als 110 herr zu minecraft abzug und
dadurch wird man dann auch getötet das
ist ganz interessant und zwar habe ich
hier schon mal so etwas aufgebaut ich
weiß nicht genau ob das funktioniert ich
wollte es nicht testen weil das pony
wieder ganz hinten war also da ganz oben
ist jetzt der amboss wartet mal so
kontraste wars crash bei vierling
endlich sportlich und jetzt bin ich
wieder am arsch der welt dabei nicht
nämlich und zwar war es das jetzt auch
eigentlich schon von diesem video das
war so alles was man bisher mit dem
amboss machen kann wenn ich irgendetwas
vergessen habe dann schreibt bitte in
die kommentare dann mache ich eben eine
anmerkung im video und zeigt euch das
dann dadurch nochmal aber ich glaube ich
hab alles gezeigt was so auch im mai
kräftig gesteht ich verlinke euch
minecraft wiki unten und außerdem die
neue version 12 442 als ich gestern
vorgestellt habe und dann würde ich
sagen würde ich mich sehr sehr dollar
einen daumen hoch freuen weil ich mir
hier mit wirklich arbeit gegeben habe
und dann würde ich sagen sie mir zum
nächsten video schau und noch einen
schönen tag euch